[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> I'm sure we have already, you know,
watched and heard different about, you
know,
>> so it's like if
Jesus is all knowing and God is all
knowing and in the Bible it says Jesus
prayed to God, you talk to God. If they
both are all knowing, then what are what
are they talking about?
>> Okay. So for for example, you love your
wife. Is that right?
>> Yep.
>> And she loves you?
>> Do you know she loves you?
>> Yep.
>> Does she know you love her?
>> Yes.
>> Good. Do you tell her?
>> For sure.
>> Does she tell you?
>> Definitely.
>> So you know your wife loves you. She She
knows you love her and yet you guys
still communicate this love with each
other. If Jesus is God and father is
also God,
are they just talking to themselves?
That's what I'm saying. No. It's kind of
they're not two two persons.
>> But that wasn't your question at first,
brother. Remember your question was if
they're all knowing, what do they talk
about? Right? What do they communicate?
>> So my my question was
>> they're both like in the sense they're
God, right?
>> Yeah. They're all knowing. They're both
God. They're both together. You're
saying if they are all knowing, what do
they have to talk about?
>> One entity. They're one entity. They're
not separate. Correct. One entity. What
are they talking about? So the to answer
to your question, similarly to how you
and your wife communicate a love that is
already known, so do the father, the
son, and the spirit communicate a love
that is already known. So it the way
that even you communicate your love is
only an imitation of how God
communicates his love within himself.
So if I talk to my wife and tell her
that I love her, that's something that
she doesn't know and I need to tell her.
>> But you told me she knows that.
>> No, no, no. You're right. Like obviously
as a husband I believe she you know she
understands but I can also have a doubt
like you know maybe she doesn't you know
>> why would you
>> generally husband and wife they have
their issues I don't doubt my wife
>> no no sometimes they have their issues
right sometimes we have our difficult
times you know what I'm saying you got
to like convince you know sometimes that
happens
>> tell me be real is there ever a time
>> that you doubt your wife loves you
>> it's not about sometimes obviously
you're in a relationship they love you
you have disagreements when I have a
question is it's about all knowing,
right? I started with that.
>> They're both all knowing, right? We're
not talking about persons here. We're
talking about gods. They're one entity.
>> And what are they talking about to
themselves? That's what I'm saying.
>> Remember I show I just told you that the
Bible says that God is love, brother. So
them being love, love is communicated.
Love is is expressed. So because God is
love at his very nature with the father,
son, and holy spirit is expressed
through those persons. So the father,
son, and spirit communicate and express
love to each other and together. Okay.
So just because it's known doesn't mean
it can't be communicated and expressed.
Okay. I I would take this uh to one more
side is if Jesus
uh prayed to God
>> and he did not pray to himself nor the
Holy Spirit.
Why after Jesus we pray to all of them
and not just you know the God himself?
Cuz as Jews they pray to God, Muslims
they pray to God.
>> What what's the difference you know
here? What's the difference? Yeah.
>> Yeah. Sure. So when it comes to Jesus,
so prayer is just communication with
God, right? That's what prayer is. It's
communication, communicating with the
divine. So one, when we see the the son
who existed with the father from
eternity's past, had that eternal union
and fellowship with the father, it's not
going to stop when he comes to earth.
What we're going to see, we're going to
visually see that communion and that
fellowship when Jesus comes on earth.
That's why we see him fellow
communicating and praying to the father.
And vice versa, we see the father doing
the same to the son. So they glorify one
another. Now when it comes to um you
know Jesus, the father, son, and spirit,
us as Christians praying to all three
and acknowledging all three is because
that's what Jesus told us to do. Jesus
look brother Jesus not only said pray
our father who is in heaven, holy is
your name. He also said whoever believes
ask me anything in my name and I will do
it. And then he also says to invoke the
Holy Spirit that whoever believes out of
his heart will flow rivers of living
water speaking of the Holy Spirit. So
Jesus talks about how the spirit is
going to come guide us, teach us and uh
you know um you know uh uh give us
strength and you know give us endurance
throughout this life. That's what he
teaches. So if what if you're saying
that uh it's all about love, right?
Jesus is love, right? And Jesus was the
son of God. Is that the belief? Right.
>> Yeah. So why was there a need of
sacrificing his beloved?
>> Yeah. Good question. Yeah. What was the
need? Yeah.
>> Yeah. So here here's the how how the
gospel is.
>> I would have one more thing to know.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> If God is almighty and all powerful,
>> why not just forgive us?
>> Exactly.
>> And then why did he create heaven and
hell?
>> You're a Muslim, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You believe in heaven and hell?
>> Exactly. We all We all believe in heaven
and hell.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> No. No. No, what I'm trying to say is if
there's a heaven and hell
>> Mhm.
>> and God sent his son and had him
sacrificed
>> for the sins of all.
>> Yeah.
>> Why heaven and hell? Why? So, what's the
logic there? You know,
>> absolutely. I got you.
>> Yeah, it's a fair question. Okay. So,
why would he have to do that in the
first place? One, God is all powerful.
You know what I'm saying? He's all
loving. Why would he send his beloved
son to die for our sins if he's all
loving and stuff like that? Here's the
here's here's what here's the issue. The
issue is is the problem of sin.
according to God's law. He has commands,
he has laws, as you know, right?
According to God's laws, it demonstrates
what he requires of us, right? And
because God is holy, he's holy, he's
perfect. His standard even for us is
holiness and perfection. Jesus even says
this. He says, "As your father is
perfect in heaven, you ought to be
perfect." The problem is is that we're
not, right? We fail. We we fall short,
right? And this is even in both of our
beliefs. And so because we fall short of
God's glory, we fall short of God's
standard. This is why God sends his son
to live out the perfect standard that we
couldn't. And so he acts, he comes in
the flesh as man and represents, okay?
And okay, he comes and represents
mankind in the flesh. That's why he
comes and takes on flesh. He represents
mankind, lives the life that we can't
live according to the father's standard
of perfection. and he dies the death
that we deserve. Takes the punishment
that we deserve because we as sinners
what we deserve the punishment. We
deserve hell and we're guilty before
God. But God loves us, right? And he's
merciful. So what what what needs to
happen is a situation where God is both
merciful and just at the same time.
Where he's merciful where he forgives
us, but he also is just in that sin is
dealt with. So because he's just, he
can't just sweep our sin under the rug.
So now we're all forgiven.
>> No, not all of us. You're forgiven
>> if if you believe in Christ.
>> If you believe. Yes. If you trust, if
you accept cuz it's it's a gift. If you
accept that gift that's given, then so
we're open to do all sins after that.
>> No. No. Absolutely not. Where uh anybody
got the Bible? Where's my Bible at?
>> Can I say
one second, sister? Because he he asked
one second. They can't hear you, sister.
We got We got to do this one at a time.
I know. Let me let me answer this
question first. I promise you I'll give
it to you. But the logic of that is not
>> I promise I'll listen. I can
>> addition to that question.
>> No, because if God is all forgiving and
all,
>> sister, I can't I can't focus on what
you're saying right now. Just one
second. Okay.
>> Wait for your question.
>> S I'm willing to hear with you out go to
Romans chapter 6 for me.
>> Got it.
>> So So your your question was good guys.
His question was so since you know we
believe in Jesus he died for our sins.
Can we just go out and sin and do what
we want? Right? That's his question. So
the Bible answers this. Okay.
>> So the Bible says this is Romans chapter
6 verse one. says, "What shall we say
then? Should we continue in sin in order
that grace may multiply?" Absolutely
not. He says, "How can we who died to
sin still live in it?" So, as believers,
we're not to continue in sin when we
believe in Jesus. We're supposed to turn
from that lifestyle and turn to Christ.
>> Okay. So, the Bible that you're
following, is it New Testament or Old
Testament?
>> Both.
>> Okay. So is this the words of Jesus
himself or like after Jesus and what was
it? Is it was this written in Jesus's
life? How do we authenticate the words?
As Muslims, we believe the Quran is
still in state 1400 plus years and it's
word by word is it's the same, you know,
how do you authenticate the book itself?
>> Good. So there's there's two ways that I
would do this. Okay. Number one,
especially from
>> you know the authors for example, do you
know the authors? Do you have the chain?
We have the chain the nar.
So what we have is called a chain of
authorship or apostolic succession. And
>> how many years later was it written?
>> Want to talk talk on this?
>> Yes. So
>> how long
>> what we know is we know at the end of
the book of acts bring that closer to
me. At the end of the book of acts what
is going on throughout Acts? Paul is on
his way to Rome. I need that one for the
live chat too. Paul is on his way to
Rome. He keeps saying he's on his way to
Rome. He's on his way to Rome. There was
an historian named Adolf von Harack. He
said, "There is no way this could have
been written
after 62 or 64 AD." Why? Because the
book of Acts ends with Paul just
arriving in Rome, foreshadowing him
going before Caesar. He never appears
before Caesar. Caesar. If anyone wrote
this after Paul was before Caesar, he
was a horrible historian. No one would
have done that. This is a time marker.
So we know Acts was written around 62 to
64 AD. Luke was written before that. So
it was written in the early 60s. He used
Mark as a source. Therefore, Mark was
written before that. Paul's letters were
written around that same time and before
that because he was martyed around 64
AD. We've got almost all the New
Testament right there before even the
Christian persecution is starting before
the destruction of the temple. All of
this is within the lifetime of
eyewitnesses.
Bring that back. So what was the
original language that the Bible was
written in and how many languages was
converted and now up to English between
how many transitions and how many
languages were there?
>> Easy question. Bring it back. Bring it
back. I got I got you on this one.
>> Yeah. Okay. He's got me on that. Yeah.
So Jesus actually was bilingual
according to numerous historians Stanley
Porter, Peter J. Williams. He could
speak Greek and Aramaic. Even very
skeptical scholars like Maurice Casey
have argued Jesus knew some Greek. So
what we see Peter J. Williams has
pointed out in his books that the sermon
on the mount was likely originally given
in Greek because when it says in Matthew
crowds were coming from gentile regions.
>> So he spoke Greek and Aramaic. Now the
New Testament was written in Greek. Paul
was originally writing in Greek.
>> The first language was
>> first language of Paul
>> the for the Bible
>> which parts because the if the Old
Testament's Hebrew and Aramaic the New
Testament was written in Greek. So what
historians can do is we can go back to
old manuscripts like Codex Cyanaticus,
Codex Vaticanis.
>> And when when was it written in which
century?
>> The Bible.
>> The first the first manuscript you just
mentioned. Yeah.
>> The manuscripts we have we have some
that date to the 3rd century, 2nd
century, we have a complete by the 4th
century. By historical standards that is
extremely close. For example, Sahi
Albakari 200 years after Muhammad, Sahi
Muslim 200 years after Muhammad. But
that was them compiling in his that was
the uh teachings of the prophet not the
not the word of God. Quran is the word
of God. It was compiled within the life
of the prophet and as a Muslim we
believe in Jesus. First thing our belief
is not complete if we don't believe in
Jesus as Adam from starting from Adam
and all the way Abraham Moses all the
prophets Jesus and then prophet Muhammad
the last messenger we believe there were
all messengers and prophets of God
bringing the same message that pray to
God and follow one God you know that was
that was the message okay that was the
message and it was never like uh even
for for Jews or or and you know even for
Muslims that there was a son. There's no
concept for us like that, you know.
>> That's in that's in the Hebrew
scripture.
>> Yeah. So So what I'm trying to say is
like it's it's not like what I'm trying
to say is like uh everyone has their own
belief and you have your own beliefs.
You have our own beliefs. You know, we
have the book and we do we do believe uh
in you know Jesus Christ himself as a
prophet, you know, as a messenger of God
and he was the mightiest messenger of
God, you know.
>> So let me ask you something. So, you do
agree with Sah 29:46.
Okay. So, I'll tell you what it says. It
says, "Do not argue with people in the
book unless you do it respectfully and
say to them, we believe in what has been
revealed to us and what has been
revealed to you. Our God and your God is
one." Do you believe that?
>> Precisely. If you believe, so we believe
in in God, God the Father. Like
technically in your terms, like for
example, No, no, no, no, no. What I'm
trying to say in your terms, in your
terms, is God the Father. Okay. in our
terms is Allah is is one God who sent
everyone. That's that's what I'm trying
to say on on your end. Yeah. Don't you
believe in what has been revealed to us
though according to surah 29:46. Right.
So the thing is uh it's what we believe
is it's the last book in which all the
corrections were there everything like
whatever was like everything is told
like what was done wrong what what you
know how even if I I don't know exactly
the the I don't know by word by word
what I'm trying to say is
>> the whole act of uh the the the whole
case of sacrifice and everything is
detailed in the Quran if you have read
the Quran and you know read about that.
Why don't you tell me from from that
perspective what the Quran says and how
it contradicts with you know the beliefs
here in in the Bible.
>> Sure. Sure. So how does the Quran
contradict the Bible
>> in the in the part of the sacrifice? In
the part of the sacrifice
>> sacrifice
what the Jesus is sacrifice
>> the crucifixion.
>> Crucifiction. Yeah. So Surah 4 157 says
Jesus wasn't crucified. Is that correct?
>> Sorry. Surah 4 157. You pull that one up
for him. Let's read that one. Surah 4
157. This is in the Quran. It's talking
about Jesus. And this is an important
one. So it's right here. It says, "And
because of their saying in boast, we
killed the Messiah, Issa, son of Miam,
the messenger of Allah. But they killed
him not nor crucified him, but it
appeared so to them." Um, as
parenthesis, I'm going to skip the
brackets. And those who differ therein
are full of doubts. They have no
knowledge. They follow nothing but
conjecture for surely they killed him
not.
Right? Talking about Jesus. So the Quran
says Jesus wasn't crucified. Was made to
appear so. The Bible says Jesus was
crucified, died, rose again, and atoned
for our sins. Okay? If sewer 29:46 says,
"You are commanded to believe in your
scriptures, the Quran, and our
scriptures, how does that work? They
contradict each other, don't they?"
>> So, I understand that they do
contradict, but obviously as as Muslims,
you believe this is the latest version.
And this is with the with the last
prophet with the last uh prophet sent by
God. And everything is detailed and
defined over there. And if you're also
reading over there, I if I can't just
open from parts, but I what I do know is
that it was a decoy that was crucified,
not Jesus himself. Okay, that's what we
believe. And Jesus will come back to
earth. Will come back to earth and Yeah.
>> No, no, not the
>> Come on, man. Don't don't have words,
you know.
So,
>> so you believe he'll come back and you
know kill the antichrist and stuff,
right? Keep going. Good to you, too.
>> I So, the thing is like uh we're just
walking over here. We're not You're
scholars. You're reading. We're not
scholars.
We're not scholars.
>> We We're not I'm not I'm not the one
standing with the books and you know
have known the fact. What I'm trying to
say is that
>> the act itself is defined in the Quran.
That's that's the message. And as us we
don't say that it was Jesus who was
crucified because he was the son of God
and God as we believe you know he loved
him. Every messenger every uh you know
uh I would say messenger of his time was
protected by God. He he just sent
me it's not like you know he would be
just sent you know in there with the
people you know just you know they can
do so. But brother, just just just in
line with this, there's there's verses
and like the verse right before that
actually talks about how the Jews killed
some of their prophets, you know, and so
Allah did in the past allow some of his
messengers to be killed. He did allow
them to be unjustly killed. So I
understand that you're saying, you know,
Jesus is beloved sacrificed or killed. I
if you're saying I I don't know exactly.
So because
>> So is was he like No. Am I talking to
you?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go get everybody. No, nobody
but in please. Please go ahead.
>> So,
>> can you wrap it up for me?
>> Yeah.
>> So, uh in like I would say just Yeah,
you're right. It's been long. So, it's
about uh what I said is it's not like
just uh them being you know, as you
said, they were attacked or killed, but
it's not the sacrifice part. That's
that's what we believe is not the part
which aligns with our belief. That's
>> okay. So, so yeah. So you so you just
take away the sacrifice part, right? Now
I I understand that. Now here's now
here's the thing. When it when it comes
to judging which is authentic, right?
What like what what got it right? Is our
Bible right that Jesus crucified or the
Quran? Right? Here's the issue. I'm not
>> the Bible was in the right in in the in
the same words in the same context. But
we believe in the Bible itself. We
believe in all the holy books. Yes.
>> You know what I'm saying? That's the
>> not not the not the revisions and the
corrections, you know, made by man.
>> You know what I'm saying? This this is
why this is important, my brother, cuz
you're what you're saying is is
extremely important. As Muslims, you
guys, like you said, you believe in the
in the Torah, the gospel, you believe in
the whole Bible, especially as it's a in
its authentic form, right? And so here
and and so here's the point, cuz I know
they're trying to get you out of here,
but here's the point. The point is is
that according to the Quran, obviously,
that the Torah and the Gospel is true.
The Quran came confirming it. And
especially in the seventh century, it
says that it says, "Let the people of
the gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed in it. And whoever doesn't
judge by what Allah has revealed, they
are the wrongdoers." So if they're
supposed to be true to what Allah is
telling them to be true to, right, the
gospel, and they read their gospel,
they're going to see that Jesus was
crucified. And because of that, they're
going to have to judge that the Quran is
false.
I I would strongly contradict with that
because of the fact like what what
doesn't settle in my heart is like this
the concept of sacrifice itself with all
due respect.
>> No no that's fine.
>> So so
you cannot let anyone harm your own
child. Let's just understand like basic
human facts. You know what I'm saying?
So God sacrificing his own son just
doesn't add. But but listen but listen
to this Jesus because I I understand you
you you see that
>> God is all in in the start. That's
exactly what I said.
>> Yeah. Let me let me God is all powerful.
Just forgive us all. You know what I'm
saying?
>> But but if he did that he wouldn't be
just if he just forgave you. Your sin is
not dealt with. It's like for example if
I robbed a bank right and I'm I'm in the
court, you know, and they got me on
camera, caught me, right?
>> So for your sin, for your crime, would
they sacrifice your child for that? No,
but I'm just I'm just talking about the
analogy of a of a judge. Would a judge
let me go if I'm sincerely sorry for
breaking into it and I say I won't do it
again and I'm serious. I'm sincere.
Tears are running down my eyes. Will the
judge let me go because I sincerely
repented for robbing the bank? Would he
let me go?
>> I I would just say why why would he
would you even consider that an offer?
>> No, I'm just I'm just saying. Would the
judge let me go if he's just
>> keeping a child in front of you? Like
that's what I'm saying. No, bro. I'm
saying if I if I rob a bank,
>> will the judge let me go? If I'm
sincerely sorry for robbing the bank and
he's a just judge,
>> will he let me go?
>> Well, robbing a bank itself, it's a big
deal, you know.
>> So, I
if you ask any judge like it's not in
his his hands, you know, just to like
forgive you for it's a crime first. It
has to be dealt with. There's he's not
like he's going to maybe pardon you from
jail or you know it there has to be a
little bit of punishment.
>> There has to be someact punishment is
there.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So the the point is is
that if even an earthly judge is just
enough to recognize he can't just sweep
the crime under the rug. Imagine how
much more just and more holy the judge
of the universe is. He cannot just sweep
our sin under the rug and just forgive
us cuz we're sorry. Sin has to be dealt
with. And so with that, with that being
done, the Bible says this, and this is
why the Bible says that the wage of sin,
the price of sin is death. That's what
it is. According to you, you think
robbing a bank is serious. Lying is
serious to God. Committing adultery is
serious to God. Committing murder or or
lusting out of something, these are
serious things to God infinitely. And so
because of this, when it comes to God,
he's just he has to deal with our sin.
But the way to do that, it something has
something has to be done. So that's why
Jesus comes willingly. He's not some,
you know, unknowing little child who
doesn't know what's going on, who's
thrown to the slaughter. He comes as the
son of God with authority and power to
take on flesh and to take on our
punishment. He does it out of love for
us. The son does it. Jesus says this. He
says, "No one takes my life for me from
me. I lay it down on my own accord." He
says, "I have the power to lay it down
and I have the authority to pick it back
up again."
>> That's what he says. He He's doing this
of his own free will.
Do do you think it's like like for would
you step in front of a bullet for your
child?
>> For sure.
>> Absolutely. That that that's what this
is like. We deserve that bullet, but
Jesus jumps in front of it.
>> He takes the bullet for us. And then but
it doesn't stop there. He rises 3 days
later with victory saying, "See, I told
you guys I am exactly who I said I am.
I'm the son of God who came down from
heaven to give you salvation to all who
will believe. But if you don't believe,
then you're condemned. But this is the
only way that your sins could be
covered.
>> So then why the concept of judgment?
Like if Jesus already told you know like
he's forgiven everyone you know.
>> Yeah.
>> So why what's the concept of judgment?
>> Because so now the only thing we have to
do is believe and and accept that gift.
It's like it's like a gift is being
offered to us my brother and all we got
to do is accept it and then we're we
we've escaped condemnation.
>> I I get that. So lastly, lastly I would
say if uh religion has to be complete in
all senses.
>> Okay. So after I just mentioned judgment
was it the what does the Bible say about
life after death and the judgment itself
and how that process is held?
>> Yeah, sure. Can you go to Matthew 25? So
I'm I'm going to show you what Jesus is
going to say cuz even Jesus talks about
how he's the one who's going to judge on
the day of judgment. Um, you're going to
around 35ish where it talks about the
coming of the son of man where he
separates the sheep and the goats. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's up here. It's
down here. It starts here.
>> Okay. So, do you do you mind if I read
this for you? All right. So, this is
Matthew. So, this is Jesus speaking
directly. He says, "When the son of man
comes in his glory, he says, "And all
the angels with him, then he will sit on
the his glorious throne." He says, "All
the nations will be gathered to him, and
he will separate them one from another
just as a shepherd separates the sheep
from the goats." So, he's talking about
what he's going to do on judgment day,
right? So, notice how Jesus puts himself
in that judgment seat in that glorious
throne. He says he's that ruler, right?
The king of the day of judgment. Um, and
then he says here, he says he will put
the sheep on his right, the goats on his
left. Then the king will say to those on
his right, "Come to you who are blessed
by my father, inherit the kingdom
prepared for you from the foundation of
the world. For I was hungry and you gave
me something to eat. You I was thirsty,
you gave me drink. Uh I was a stranger,
you took me in. I was naked, you clothed
me. I was in prison and sick and you
visited me." And then the righteous will
say, "Lord, when did we see you hungry
or thirsty and give you food and drink?
When did we see you sick and visit you
or in prison and visit you?" And he will
say, "Um uh I lost my part." He says, "I
assure you, whatever you did to to one
of the least of my brothers, then you
did it to me." Then he will say to those
on his left, "Depart from me, you who
are cursed into the eternal fire
prepared for the devil and his and his
angels. For I was hungry, you did not
give me food." And so on and so same
thing he said to them, right? And then
uh he goes on and says, "So then they
too will answer, Lord, when did we do
this and not and not give you food and
drink?" He'll say the same thing. And he
says, "And they will go away into
eternal punishment, but the righteous
into eternal life." So Christ is the one
who raises up. Christ is the one who
will come judge on the day of judgment.
He's going to call out the dead people
from their tombs. They're going to rise
from the dead and he's going to judge
give reward to the righteous and give
punishment to the uh to the unrighteous.
>> Okay. So uh the conversation was pretty
good. We had uh good discussion. Uh
lastly I would just uh mention is like
although I we're Muslims and you know we
uh you know you're a Christian we all
have our beliefs and
>> we fall under the same Abrahamic
religion. Okay. So, and I would say uh
right now me talking initially it's it's
not just for any uh as you put in the
science money or anything but I would
welcome you know like uh ask you is like
just how we're here and uh right in
Central Park in New York you know I
would welcome you to you know come over
there in the speaker corner and someday
you know talk about that with the uh
brothers and scholars over there.
>> You said in c in Central Park here in
New York.
>> Yeah.
>> They they set up a dama table. It's it's
a it's a speaker corner for everyone and
they are speaking in different corners
you know if you are you guys can come
over there so you know
>> so so so do they like just really cuz
I'm you know they they give da open dav
over there and you will find better
answers over there you know that's what
I'm saying cuz I don't have exactly all
areas of knowledge yeah and but if you
go over there talk with the same level
I'm pretty sure it will be a better
discussion over there
>> sure so I I want to say this before you
leave cuz won. I appreciated you
stepping up. Very brave. Matter of fact,
guys, if you guys can give it up for
him, we did step up and have the
conversation. It's very respectful. Um,
so, and the last thing I would say is
this, like, please consider what we're
talking about, right? Because this is
the reason why I'm out here is because I
believe it is life or death. It's heaven
or hell. And I love you enough to be
like, man, I want you to believe in the
gospel. Obviously, you want, you know,
me to consider Islam, right? So, we want
each other to believe that. And so
consider what we're talking about that
like it's really huge that the Quran
affirms the scriptures but at the same
time it's contradicting the scriptures.
Right? So if the scriptures are
authentic and look into this if the
Bible's authentic cuz if it is a
>> how many versions of the Bible do we
have and how many versions of the Quran
we have?
>> We got quite a few versions of the Quran
brother.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you show me which version?
>> Oh yeah. See I knew I should have
brought
>> it up. Okay sure. So
>> how many you saying there are versions
of the Quran? Absolutely. of of the
context
>> of of the Quran in Arabic. Yes. In
Arabic.
>> Yes. I don't have my phone, but You got
your phone?
>> You got your phone? I'll
>> show them.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So, no, cuz he wants
to see this.
>> Listen, this is this is recorded, right?
>> Yes, sir. And
>> I can't lie.
>> Okay. So, what? Do do one thing. Do me a
favor. After this this video,
>> just take the version of the Quran and,
you know, we'll we'll go from there.
>> All right. Sounds good.
>> Sure.
>> I'm pretty sure you're you are talking
about the English translation. I'm
saying. No, brother.
>> No, I'm talking about the Arabic
context. Arabic
>> that's what I'm saying.
>> These are different Arabic Qurans.
>> The worship the
No.
>> Yes. Those are different Arabic Qurans,
not English, brother. These are Arabic
Qurans.
>> Yes, bro. They are the names of the
readers over there. And
>> Uh-huh.
>> Yeah. Where is this from? What what
where are you referencing from? Whatever
versions of the Quran, Muslim,
>> Brother, I have I have like uh four of
these Qurans in my home. The different
ones. So I have I have look I have what
is called hops I have worsh I have koon
and I have kof listen out of a quarter
of the population being Muslims
in my whole life there has never been
any other version of the Quran as what
you're stating
>> I know
>> I would just like you to add the put the
description the link I'll give it
>> in the description sir
>> and I will personally view that do you
read do you read do you read Arabic by
the way
>> yes
>> oh okay that's perfect yeah so I'll do
exactly what you said. I I'll post the
link and
>> send the Arabic.
>> Yes, brother. I'm telling you these are
not English translations.
>> All right. I'm going to get your number
so you can give me that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But listen, this was a
pleasure talking to you, my friend.
Yeah. Very nice conversation.
>> Dory.
>> All right. Yeah. That's awesome. That's
awesome.